the three of us got back together and it
was like just riding a bike it was like
we're back
[Music]
the cast of icarly is back together and
dishing new secrets to et
about the upcoming paramount plus
revival series
it feels kind of crazy we did the first
table read about a week or so ago
and it was kind of insane like just
getting everybody back together again
and it was really fun did you find were
you like
was it easy for you i kind of thought it
was yeah yeah
yeah we shot a promo a little while ago
and it was like the three of us got back
together and it was like
just riding a bike it was like we're
back yeah and the cool part is what
makes it different too is we have new
characters that are coming as well so it
is
a lot of the familiar you know it's a
lot of familiar faces but there's new
people involved that are going to change
up the story a ton
and make it very interesting and i think
somewhat unexpected
changing things up are lacie mosley as
carly's best friend harper and
jaden triplett who will be playing
freddy's step-daughter
i have a kid now that changes the
dynamic a little bit
uh instead of the show yes he is a kid
right also don't you
in real life also in real life yes he
also has a kid yeah in like two weeks
you're gonna have
yeah in two weeks i'll have two kids
yeah so just kids everywhere
i have no kids thank goodness
miranda no kids in the show
no kids when fans last saw carly and
freddy the two shared a goodbye kiss
in the series finale but what's their
relationship status in the icarly
revival
tbds i don't know
i have no idea and even if i didn't know
i wouldn't tell you
we gotta we gotta keep things spicy for
the folks at home can't say
right miranda too juicy
see i feel like there's a lot of secrets
yeah we don't know
when we're gonna get in trouble for uh
saying too much i'll say the scripts are
really funny
i i don't think anybody's expecting
what we're doing what we're doing i just
don't think
it's i don't think a revival's been done
quite this way
yeah that'd be nice
[Music]
you